(bright upbeat music)
- Well, welcome back to another
episode of the "Addy Hour."
I'm honored today to be
able to host a conversation
about oxytocin and social behavior,
community and mental health.
In a lot of ways, these
topics have come up
in a lot of our conversations
on this podcast already,
but we really haven't been
able to dig into the science
of social behavior and community.
So today I'm honored
to be able to host two revered scientists,
a revered scientist and philosopher,
and luminaries in this area
to really engage in this conversation.
So the first guest I'd like to
introduce is Dr. Larry Young.
Larry is a director
of the Center for Translational
Social Neuroscience
and the director of the Silvio O. Conte
Center for Oxytocin and Social Cognition
at Emory University in Atlanta.
He's also the William P.
Timmie Professor of Psychiatry
at the Emory School of Medicine.
And he leads the Center
for Social Neural Networks
at the University of Tsukuba in Japan.
So quite a few different leadership roles.
He's someone who's also been a
recipient of numerous awards,
including the Golden Brain
Award, the Frank Beach Award,
the ACNP Daniel H. Efron Award,
and he's a fellow
in the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences.
His research focuses on the
neurobiological mechanisms
underlying social relationships,
and how we can translate some of that
into treatments for psychiatric illnesses
with social deficits, such as autism.
He's someone that I had the
pleasure of interacting with
over the years as a fellow neuroscientist.
He's actually hosted me at his institution
and served in some
mentoring roles as well,
which I'm really grateful for.
So today I'm honored to be
able to welcome him here
to the "Addy Hour" podcast.
Thanks for being here, Larry.
- Thank you for inviting me.
It's wonderful, thank you.
- The second guest which
I'd like to introduce
is Dr. Patricia Smith Churchland,
who is a professor emerita of philosophy
at the University of California San Diego
and also an adjunct professor
at the Salk Institute.
She is someone who has been a pioneer
in several different ways,
specifically, her work focuses
on discoveries in neuroscience
and how that impacts
traditional philosophical ideas.
She's the author of several books,
one, the pioneer book, "Neurophilosophy,"
but also the book "The
Computational Brain,"
also "Braintrust:
What Neuroscience Tells
Us about Morality,"
"Touching A Nerve,"
"Conscience: The Origins
of Moral Intuition."
And she has been just a celebrated speaker
over the years as well,
having had listened to some of her recent
and talks from a few years back,
I've been really impressed with the way
that she really has brought
this neurophilosophy
to the forefront.
She's someone who's
been the past president
of the American Philosophical Association
and The Society for
Philosophy and Psychology.
She won a MacArthur Prize in 1991,
a Rossi Prize for Neuroscience in 2008,
and a PROSE Prize for Science
for her book "Braintrust."
She's someone, again, as I
mentioned, who's very celebrated,
who was also a previous
philosophy department chair
at the University of California San Diego.
So I'm honored to be able
to welcome Pat Churchland
to the "Addy Hour" podcast as well.
Thanks for being here.
- Thanks so much for having me.
It's really a great pleasure.
- Well, I'm grateful to both of you
for the work that you do.
And again, this I think is a conversation
that's been a long time
coming on this podcast
as these topics
and your names have actually
come up on previous episodes,
so full circle for us in a lot of ways.
But as my listeners know,
I often just like to
start out and check in
with how people are doing.
Both of you as we can hear from your CVs,
have very active lives.
And so I'm curious to know
how you're both doing in this moment
and also what occupies you and
your time on a daily basis?
So Pat, actually, if we
could start with you,
that'd be great.
- Well, I'm doing very well
actually, but I'm retired.
And so I can do what I want with my days.
And I find that to be an
absolutely amazing experience.
So I do a lot of reading, of course,
but I also walk the dog a lot,
and I do about an hour of yoga every day
and meet up with my friends
for drinks in the afternoon
and like that.
I also watch some football.
- Wow, so a full plate.
I mean, that's encouraging
to hear how active you are.
You said you're retired,
but you sound still very
active in a lot of ways,
which is excellent.
- Lots of ways, yeah.
Well, at a certain point,
of course, your body will
tell you you're done.
And it hasn't told me that yet,
so I'm still going.
- Excellent, excellent.
Larry, what about you?
- Yeah, things are going
real well with us here.
We're able to work in the lab
and come to work every day and see people.
There was a time when we
didn't get to do that,
and that really was strange.
And I didn't like that very much,
but so far we've been able
to adjust pretty well.
During the pandemic,
I decided to really try to get healthy,
and I started exercising.
So now every day I sort
of start my day off
with an exercise routine
and come into work
and just try to get as much
social interaction as I can.
One thing I do miss though
is being able to travel as
much as I used to be able to,
really meeting other
scientists face to face.
That's so important.
And we've just been missing
that for a long time now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I find that too.
I mean, I find that Zoom works quite well
when you're talking to
people you already know.
But if like I'm going
to be giving a Zoom talk
to folks in Saudi Arabia,
and I would so much rather be there
and then have a chance
to interact with them
and talk about the work and so forth.
And so that is disappointing,
but really in the long haul of life,
it's not something I can complain about.
- Right, right.
But just that opportunity
that we had before to,
I mean, in a sense, experience the culture
in a different way than you would-
- Absolutely.
- On the computer.
Yeah, yeah, so that makes a lot of sense.
I know we're gonna get
to the social behavior piece eventually,
but it's just, as I'm
listening to both of you talk
and thinking about your areas of research,
and as you're sharing about the losses
of having those connections,
I think a lot of things are
full circle in some ways,
although I will start with
a question, in a sense,
for both of you,
do you think, even as people
who study social behavior,
did it catch you off guard at all
at how much we've missed those rhythms
or how it's affected us,
or would you say that
was completely expected?
- Well, I don't know.
I think people do vary,
both as a function of temperament
and as a function of age
and what kinds of routines and skills
and so forth they have
and how much the isolation
has affected them.
It affects everybody to
some degree of course,
but it's clear that some people
are much more deeply
bothered by it than others.
And I'm not quite sure
scientifically what that tells us.
- Right, right.
- Yeah. I agree.
I think that there are some people who,
well, maybe at first they
feel they're thriving
by being at home and
maybe they're introverted.
They don't, somehow social interactions
are a little bit, give them anxiety.
But then I think that
by completely avoiding
those social interactions,
but even when we have the opportunity now,
I think that's really
doing maybe some damage
to their mental health,
and especially if they continue
to avoid the social interactions
because they really are healthy.
- Yeah.
- Although it's funny,
I was reflecting on all of this
and thinking about
I grew up in this very remote
area of British Columbia
and there were lots of people
who would be off
prospecting in the mountains
for months and months on
end, maybe not even a dog.
And then there were the fur trappers
a little bit further North
who would be out in the
Bush all winter trapping.
And then they would come in
in the spring with their furs
and they poop it up a little bit.
And back they though.
And it made me wonder,
is it perhaps that the
expectation of sociality
and then not getting
that we find particularly painful
because I mean these old
prospectors and fur trappers,
well, their social skills were terrific.
As you may imagine then of course,
they certainly needed a bath.
But on the other hand,
they did not seem to
have suffered mentally
as a result of being on
their own for so long.
And I mean, it was just part of life then.
But now I'm back on,
and I think, how did those guys do that?
- Yeah, well, yeah.
I think certainly there's
individual variation
in how much we need social interactions.
But I think for young people
it's especially important
because there's still developing.
I mean, students and graduate students
and people that are early
phases of their career,
I think that social
interactions is so important
for building the networks
that help them succeed.
Those trappers maybe they were
already fixed in their ways
and all they needed to do is trap.
- Probably were.
- So but they're building
that social skills
because things are going to change again
in two, three, four years.
Our livelihood is going to
require social interactions
and social skills.
I'm just afraid that some people
they're missing element
on the normal development
of those skills.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah. I think those are
really important points.
I'm intrigued about that.
Not that there's a clear answer,
but the expectation component too,
and how that plays into it.
So I mean, you could just hear
that in the public discourse
and how much angst there seemed to be
around the expectation to be together
and the inability to be able to do that,
and to have to facilitate
it through other means.
And then Larry to your point,
I mean, all the developmental components,
I mean, there's obviously an
intersection there as well.
I know that that's something
that people will try
and look at down the road
is definitely a question that
will have long-term impacts.
I mean, just developmentally
thinking about how,
I mean, even if we think
about younger kids,
preschool and elementary school,
what impact this is going
to have down the road
for their social development.
- Even those kids they're going to school
and they've went for a couple of years
not seeing the faces of other kids
or their facial expression.
We learn from those real
social interactions,
those rewiring that
happens to help us learn
what other people are
thinking, reading emotions,
and they're missing that.
And I think it's really kind of opened up
a whole new field of study
for the next decade or so.
What has been the impact of this.
The other thing that's
changing things so much
COVID came, this Zoom
and the ability to interact
so easily over Zoom.
And that's sort of really taking the place
of a lot of regular social interactions
and what are the consequences of that,
and also dating.
People have had a hard time dating.
It's really and now...
So for a couple of years,
people will have to
date in a different way.
And so that can have a long
lasting impact as well.
- So much to process and think about,
I definitely want to come back to that,
but even as we've already
touched on so many topics
about development and the
social interactions as well.
I want to just take a step back
and have you all actually take us through
the science and philosophy
of the social bio and
social relationships.
'Cause I know so many of our audience
are familiar with that.
Some are vaguely familiar with it,
have heard about oxytocin a little bit,
or I've heard about the love hormone
as people sometimes make it
out to be over simplistic.
But in a sense, just want
to go and start there
and have you share what we know
both from your own research
and your own thinking
and from the field as well.
So Larry, can you take us through
a little bit of the biology
of what we know at this point?
- Yeah. Well, let me first
say something about oxytocin
since you mentioned that,
'cause this is a really important molecule
for social interactions,
and it was first discovered
for its role in giving birth.
It's the molecule that's
released from the mother's brain
when it's time to give birth
and it causes uterus contractions.
And then after the baby is born,
the baby begins to circle, to nurse.
The oxytocin is released to eject the milk
so the baby can get the milk to thrive.
But what we also know is that
it's also acting in the brain
to focus the attention
of the mother to the baby
and to bond with that baby
and to feel a real sense of connection.
And that was some of the first knowledge
that we knew about oxytocin
and social behavior.
And then in my work, we started
working with these voles.
These are little rodents,
they look like hamsters,
they're natural animals
that live out in the
Midwest United States.
And there were two
different kinds of voles.
There was one called the Prairie vole,
which is, they have a family life,
very similar to our own.
Male and female come together, they mate.
After mating, a transformation
happens in the brain
and they form a bond
and then they basically
live in that partnership
for the rest of their life.
They raise their offspring together.
Then the other species is a meadow vole,
they're solitary, they're
like those trappers.
They prefer to be by themselves.
So we've been studying them to see
what is the chemistry of that
bond in the prairie voles.
And it turns out that oxytocin,
the same molecule that's
responsible for giving birth
is also helping to seal that bond
between these prairie voles
that bond that lasts a lifetime.
And oxytocin interacts with
other molecules like dopamine,
which is involved in reward and pleasure
in the opiate system.
And what we've kind of learned
is that a pair bond, at least
the strong romantic bond
is very much like an
addiction to a partner.
But now we know oxytocin
is also really important for
many other kinds of bonds.
Bonds between a dog and the owner.
When your dog looks at you in the eyes,
it causes you to release oxytocin
and then you want to nurture that dog.
Also just social touch,
looking eye to eye contact
causes oxytocin release.
And it seems that what
oxytocin is really doing
is helping tune the brain
into the social stimuli
so that we pay attention to that
and can navigate our social
world in the appropriate way.
- Excellent. Well, thanks
for taking us through.
I know a lot of people are
going to be just enlightened
with that information,
and it's great to have
that understanding again,
'cause it's come up in
so many different ways.
And Pat, as someone who has expertise
both in neuroscience and in philosophy
or more appropriately in neuro philosophy,
and he was also engaged in this,
how has this information
informed your work
and your conversations with people
around these aspects of bonding?
- It's huge, of course,
because in one respect,
it really constitutes the platform
for what we call morality.
But I want to step back
and because the sort
of bonding that we see
in mammals and birds is really unique.
And so you want to say,
well, because many people
have been very skeptical
of the idea.
Richard Dawkins actually is one
that there could be genuine altruism
that I could,
as it were sacrificed,
something that I want
for the good of another.
And so the idea is that
that could never evolve
because if there were
altruistic individuals,
always selfish guys would
take advantage of that's that.
So part of what really motivated me
after I learned about the voles from Larry
was why would this happen?
Why would there be this kind of evolution?
And I think the story
actually goes way, way back,
about 200 million years
to the fact that warm bloodedness
appeared on the face of the planet.
And the great thing
about being warm blooded
is that you can forage at night.
All those other guys have to
wait for the sun to come up
but you can forage at night.
But as with many sort
of changes in evolution,
there's a downside.
And the downside is that gram for gram,
a warm blooded animal has
to eat 10 times as much.
Now that's a huge evolutionary constraint.
As you know, you can go off
and leave your lizard alone for a week
and it's not going to be
starving when you get back.
It doesn't need to eat that much.
And also lizards and snakes
don't take care of their young.
They just have them and off they go.
So what happened such that mothers
and in any cases, fathers,
especially in birds,
do this amazing thing,
which has made this enormous
sacrifice for their offspring?
And the answer is this,
that to meet this ecological
constraint of eating so much,
getting so much energy,
basically mother nature
invented the cortex,
and that's a way of letting the animals
learn a huge amount
about their environment,
and hence in a certain
sense, makes them smart.
Birds have cortex too.
It doesn't look like it.
It's just a little different from ours.
So, okay. But if you're going
to have cortex, then what?
It better not be already fully developed.
It better be so immature
that the baby can learn
from its environment.
And that means the offspring
are born very, very immature.
So then mother nature has a problem.
Well, if they're that immature,
they're not like a turtle,
like they can just come out
of an egg and off they go.
The baby mouse can't do anything
it's deaf and blind inheritance.
And we're pretty bad too.
So you'll have to have
some sort of mechanism.
And this is what obviously
evolved in mammals and birds,
some sort of mechanism whereby
the thing that gives birth
is also the thing that
begins to take care of it.
And oxytocin, although it
was plentiful in the body
all over the place for
hundreds of millions of years,
was put to a very new role.
And that role had to do with
bonding and feeling good
when you were with the baby,
feeling bad when the babies were gone
or if they were being
predated and so forth.
So that I think it puts morality
into a completely different perspective
from what most of the
evolutionary biologists
had thought for so long.
Namely, that it has to
be beaten into kids.
No other animal has anything like it
because it goes against evolution.
And the answer is nuts.
It is an evolutionary development.
So there's more of course to the story.
But I like the fact that
something as in direct
shall we say, as being warm blooded
turns out to be the essential part
of the causal story for the emergence.
So something like attachment and bonding,
which is the essential
platform for morality.
- Hmm. So much there.
And so many things that we
can pick up already too.
And one thing I'd like
to just follow up on,
'cause we started talking
about this developmental piece
a little bit already too.
So what are the implications of that?
'Cause you talked about the young
not having that developed cortex yet
and needing that bonding.
So were the implications of that bonding
happening early on for life down the road
and free to who wants to jump into that?
- Well, I've just held for,
so I'm going to let Larry start with that,
but I'll talk about Allison
Perkeybile's work too.
- Yeah. So we've done some
interesting work in the voles
that show that if the pups experience
a little bit of neglect,
so they don't get as much licking
and grooming from their mother.
That licking and grooming
causes oxytocin release in the brain.
And if for the first two weeks of life,
they get less of that,
then when they grow up,
they actually have a difficulty
forming relationships as adults.
So this work suggests that as an infant,
as the infant's brain is developing,
the kind of nurturing that
it gets from the parents,
the eye to eye contact,
the talking, the touching,
all of that stuff is causing
a series of chemical events
in the brain, such as
the release of oxytocin,
that's help constructing the circuitry
that determines how that individual
is going to be able to relate
to others later in life.
And I think that that's a huge,
you had such huge societal implications
because before knowing
this kind of research,
people just think well, the baby is born,
they're going to develop, however.
But their future child, your adult child
really depends on how
you nurture that child.
It's really, really critical.
- I think a part of the story
that we haven't really touched on,
that's so important here
is that the other part of oxytocin,
and that is the receptor on a neuron
to which the oxytocin binds
because what Larry and
his cohort discovered,
was that it's the density
of oxytocin receptors
in very specific parts of the brain
that determines whether or not
you're going to be a
long-term parabonder or not.
And similarly, we see that in some mammals
there aren't male-female
bonds that are super strong,
like in baboons.
But what there are are matchlikes
the head lady and her daughters
and her daughters and her
daughters and so forth.
And so we can see that just
by the subtle alterations
of the pattern of where
the oxytocin receptors are,
you get changes.
So to follow up on the developmental point
that Larry was making,
Allison Perkeybile's
show that when baby mice
are taken from the mother
and for even just a few hours a day,
and they're not, like they're groomed,
but they're fed and kept warm
and then they're put back.
What you see is a lowering
of the density of receptors
in the places where you would expect it.
And like Larry's work with voles,
what she found was that when those animals
then become mothers, they
are so to speak bad mothers.
They don't really care that much.
They don't bond much to their babies.
I mean, they don't have the mechanism.
They don't have the
receptors for the oxytocin
to latch onto.
And so I agree with Larry,
I think this is just
super, super important.
I mean, we all knew
that it wasn't very good
to put those Romanian orphans in cribs
and leave them there for years.
But we understand in a very direct way now
why it was so terrible.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And that's so powerful.
I mean, what you both mentioned,
just having that understanding
of the brain mechanisms
that impacts down the road.
Go ahead, Larry.
- Yeah. I was just saying,
we did another study,
the first study that
I mentioned was about,
when neglect, where the pups
were like sort of left alone
for three hours a day.
Only three hours a day,
that's not (indistinct).
- I know, it's amazing.
- But we also did experiments
where they were raised by only the mom
or the mom and the dad.
And so in the case with only the mom,
the mom had the forage for food
and left the pups alone in the nest
for a certain amount of time.
Or when they were both parents were there,
they were always had a parent
that was engaged with the pups.
Even the pups that were
raised only by the mother
with just one parent,
they had more difficulty
forming relationships
later in life.
So it is not just at the extremes.
So I think the lesson from that-
- That's very interesting.
- That it is the sort of the
total amount of nurturing
that individuals give, that babies give,
whether it comes from their grandmother
from their aunt or from their father,
or from the mother,
all of that sort of
accumulative kind of thing.
And you can think of it in your babies,
this is a project that you're working on
you're trying to build
a healthy individual
for the next generation.
- Absolutely. Yeah.
That is a beautiful experiment, actually.
I didn't know about that.
- Yeah, definitely it's fascinating.
And for those who are listening,
who may be hearing a lot of this,
the science for the first time too,
I imagine there's both
fascinating and intimidating
at the same time,
because even as you're describing
some of the experiments,
one perspective could be
well if that's happened,
does that mean that that person
is now set to have disrupted
relationships going forward?
Or are there things that happened later on
that can also still have
effects on the brain
when we talk about changes
in the brain plasticity?
So how do those processes
later on in life also intersect
with some of these early differences
that you've talked about?
Whether someone, if we think about humans,
if people have had neglect
in certain situations,
is that something,
are they stuck in that category?
What happens down the road?
- They're not.
I don't think that they're
stuck in that category,
but they have that trajectory.
And if that trajectory isn't changed,
that trajectory can change
as they reach adolescence
or pass adolescence
or even, as in adults.
But it needs the attention to do that.
Either that individual
or someone needs to say,
okay, I need to engage in things
that would put me in the right direction.
And so it's just as long as we are aware.
So, even genes.
We often hear genes predict behavior,
but having a gene doesn't mean
that you have to engage in
that behavior that it predicts.
It's just, these are all just vectors
that sort of point people
in certain directions.
And if left alone,
they will continue to
go in that direction.
But the knowledge that
these are deflectors
that are pointing people in directions,
and we know that that's
not the right direction,
we should think of ways
to change the direction.
'Cause it means,
health and happiness all
the way through life,
we live way past our
childhood and we don't wanna,
if we had difficulty in childhood,
we don't want to be
stuck with the remnants
of that difficulty.
We want to fix those.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I sometimes think of
those small communities
of hunter gatherers or people like,
small groups of Inuits,
maybe 10 or 20 living in a small community
where somebody is always there.
Somebody is always carrying
the baby in the hood.
And I do think city life
makes things a little more
difficult, shall we say.
We don't always know the people next door.
So we don't always pitch in
when we know that the baby
really needs a certain
amount of cuddling and care.
- Yeah. Really well said.
Well, I appreciate the context
that you've both put this in
and with the biology of it as well.
Anyway, I think of both of you
as really excellent communicators
and excellent scientific communicators
in terms of taking this
knowledge that we have
and making sure
that it's part of the public discourse.
Would you say that in terms of,
I mean, everything that
you both have described
and what we've learned about
the importance of these bonds,
are we really paying attention
to that enough as a society?
Or are there more things that we should do
'cause Larry even talked about,
if those things happen early on,
we can change the direction.
And I'm wondering even
what are some of the ways
that we do change that trajectory?
I know I just asked two
questions at once, but.
- Yeah, I was thinking of the first one.
It depends on the society
because in many countries like Sweden,
they have enacted laws and policies
that really enhance
the parental engagement
with paternal leave from work
and longer time with the child.
So in this country,
we lag behind some other countries.
But I think that we are,
I mean, slowly gaining this understanding
much more than we were
20, 40, 60 years ago.
So we are making improvements.
And as science goes forward,
this is the business we're in.
Science is trying to figure out
how things work and how
to make things better.
I think that we are moving
in the right direction
just by appreciating the biology.
- I think the other part of the story too
that needs emphasis is that
it isn't just that the
child needs to be cuddled
and so forth.
It also, especially in humans,
but also dogs and many
kinds of species of mammals.
The infants are hugely
disposed to imitate others,
adult siblings, and so forth.
And how they learn the
norms of their group
is from watching and interacting
and doing things and being told, yes, yes,
that's great.
Or no, you don't want
to do that and so forth.
And this is a part of the story
that engages a very ancient system.
And that is the reward system,
which is largely subcortical,
but of course has very dense interactions
with cortex as well.
And so it's really important
not only that the children
are loved and nurtured,
but they also have the opportunities
to interact in social ways
so that they come to understand
that on the whole, truth
telling is better than Fitbit.
And that disagreements
can best be resolved
sometimes by working it out,
rather than by bonking somebody
on the noggin and so on.
But they need to pick these things up.
And if they are raised in circumstances
that are really grim,
they're going to pick up
very different kinds of norms
and then it's going to
be hard to undo those.
And so I think that's a
reason why family life
and extended family life
are really very important.
Why grandparents have an
important role to play
and as well as siblings and
aunts and uncles and neighbors
and dogs.
So yeah, it is.
I mean, dogs teach kids a lot
and that's their learning norms
that most of us can't
even articulate even now,
but we know, we know.
- Yeah, that's so important.
And again, it seems that
there's just a lot of bonus
on each member of the
family and the community
in so many different ways.
I mean, I'm wondering also,
just from a philosophical perspective,
what does that say about us as humans
and the importance of altruism?
I mean, as we have learned about
all these different outcomes
and effects that these
interaction is going to have
on our fellow human beings.
What responsibility would you say
that has for us as fellow humans?
- Well, I think,
even in small hunter gatherer groups,
people understand in a very deep way
the importance of cooperation
and mutual defense
and so forth.
And I think that children are
very quick to pick that up.
We also see in cross species alliances,
for example, between wolves and humans
or between wolves and gelada baboons
that there can be very close relationships
because they cooperate with each other.
And that's really valuable
in the case of us and the baboons,
the wolves are very important
in helping to drive off predators.
And in return, the baboons tolerate them,
they don't snuggle with them
in the way we snuggle with dogs.
But maybe it took us a
few generations as well
I don't know.
- Well, I think one of the
interesting things about altruism
is that we've learned from,
well, in work with
animals but also in humans
is that we tend to think
of others in our species
as either within our group or out-group.
And so we exhibit altruistic behavior
towards those that are in our group.
And altruistic behavior
is someone needs help and you help them,
you detect that they need the help,
and then you help them.
And I think that evolved
from the brain mechanisms
of maternal behavior,
because mothers are always altruistic.
They can hear their pup being
in distress or their baby,
a Wildebeest can be as can see their baby
being approached by a lion,
then they'll risk their
life to help their baby.
But I think in humans
the same neuro-biological processes
have been expanded to others in our group
because when we help our group,
our group does better.
The problem is, is who
do we see as in our group
and who do we see outside of our group?
And I think that those divisions
of who's us and who's not,
I mean, you can see it in
politics right now, us and them.
And so that kind of division
was something that we
really need to grapple with
how to erase those boundaries and sort of,
so that the group becomes all of us.
- And increasingly I think,
people are recognizing that
because the planet isn't
an infinitely large place,
and because things like
climate affect us all,
that we do need to cooperate
with people that we don't know
and maybe never see and so forth.
Nevertheless, I think the strongest,
I think this is almost
certainly to remain the case,
but the strongest desire for help
and reaching out and so
forth, is going to be local.
I mean, there is a group of philosophers
who say that's wrong,
that it should always be
the person who's most needy
wherever they are on the planet.
And like I have this friend
who cuts people's hair.
I mean, she's a hairdresser, I guess.
And a couple of times a month,
she takes her tools and chair
and goes down and cuts the
hair of homeless people.
And maybe they don't need her time
as much as somebody else on
the other side of the planet.
But I think it's asking
too much to ask her
to figure out who really needs her help
and to quit running downtown
to cut the hair of the homeless people.
On the other hand, where I
absolutely agree with Larry
is that we don't want to let localness
kind of be the enemy of
looking further a field
when it's really important to do so.
And so we have to both be
motivated as we all are
when it's somebody we know.
But we also don't want to have
the sort of in-group thing
where we're the good guys
and they're the bad guys.
That's when the trouble starts.
- Yeah. Yeah.
So many important pieces there.
And I love how you've tied
in that aspect of altruism
and just what the science has showed us
about the within group
versus the without group.
So many directions I could go
and I'm formulating the ideas
as I talk through this.
So bear with me as we go through it.
But I mean, that's just something
that we've thought a lot
about on this podcast,
as well as we've talked about
aspects of social justice.
And even Larry, as you were talking,
it reminded me of those components
through thinking who is within
the group and who is outside
and the benefits of helping
those within our group.
But then also on the flip side,
the detriments of things
that happen within the group.
So I've referenced a couple of times,
some of David Williams work at Harvard
looking specifically at
black and brown communities
and the long-term detrimental
mental health effects
when there are individuals
in those communities
who are killed at the hands of police
when they're unharmed.
So the way it goes both ways.
And so even as we're talking
about this just makes me think,
and not that there's
evidence for this per se,
but the power of expanding those groups
and what that would do for
us collectively as a society,
whether there would be some of
these aspects of the bonding
that would happen from
biological perspective
that would have long-term
effects even in adults,
even though we're passing.
- Yeah, no, I agree.
I mean, and there is
some work on chimpanzees
where the fielded servers
were watching two groups
because they were both
getting rather large,
and they rather suspected
that there was going to be
a bit of a fight eventually,
which there was,
but they managed to collect urine samples
from the members of the group
before and after the incident.
The oxytocin levels had
gone through the roof.
These guys were, they
were all of a sudden,
so bonded to each other.
And also probably, I mean,
Larry could speak to this better than I,
their stress levels had gone down.
And so they weren't quite as afraid.
And boy did they go at it.
And that's very biological.
Now are humans like that?
It would surprise me if we
didn't see it, for example,
in football teams or basketball teams,
maybe baseball's too slow for it.
- Yeah, you certainly do.
If you give someone oxytocin
and you tell them that these
people are on your team,
you're more likely to do
something altruistic to them
and maybe be more defensive
to someone who is taught the
word old is not on your team.
And so, I think that-
- That's a better deal.
- It's a very difficult thing
in terms of racism in the
society and to fix it right away.
It's not going to be an
instant fix of course,
but if by thinking about this,
the biology of responding
to in-groups and out-groups,
what we need to do is to try
to think of ways, move forward in ways
so that our skin color is not a factor
to determine in-group versus out-group.
And that can be done
through making sure that
the diversity is represented
in all aspects of our lives.
So we can see, whatever we are doing,
there's a lot of different kinds of people
that are also like that.
And rather than...
And it just takes time to reach everybody
in that kind of way.
- Yeah.
- I think that's probably true.
I mean, I would love for
these things to move faster,
but I'm always gratified
when I see how, for example,
sportscasters and newscasters in general,
how it used to be your basic white male
and now there's women,
there's people of color,
there's all kinds.
And because people watch
television so much,
I mean, maybe I'm just
being foolishly optimistic,
but I think those things matter,
and I think it is making a difference.
But we've got a long way to go.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Well, I appreciate the way
that you both framed that as well.
And then even as we've been talking,
thinking back to some
of the earlier comments
that we had in the conversation too,
it also makes me wonder,
and this is getting a little speculative,
but just about those
bonds early in life too,
early in childhood,
if there are windows of opportunity
to expand that circle in a sense,
like you were talking about Larry.
Is that bonds formed earlier,
and that there's less of this,
we and them, us and them kind
of framework from early on.
And whether, from a
biological perspective,
whether that would also
have long-term effects
as people become adults.
And again, I'm speculating,
but just as we're having this conversation
and thinking through some
of those topics as well.
- Yeah, I think so.
I mean, there was some work done in rats
where you have rats that have
the different patterns of fur
and if they are raised with other rats
that have a different
color pattern of fur,
then they were more likely to
show helpful behavior to them.
So early learning is important.
- [Patricia] I think so.
- And so, I think
this is just something
that we as a society
have to recognize as important
and just pay attention to that
and increase exposure
to all kinds of people
so that the skin color
and all of these things
nationality or ethnic background
are not the divisors of groups.
- Yeah, no, I remember when I
was at first grade in school,
again, this is in this tiny little school
in British Columbia.
And there was an influx of kids
who wore leather pants that
were cut off above the knees.
And of course what had happened
was that there were a number of Germans
who were moved to this area to farm
and start a new life after the war.
And we were all absolutely
fascinated by this.
And of course, by the fact
that they didn't talk like us.
But when you're only six,
these things don't matter very much.
So within I don't know,
six months or whatever
it was all kind of,
they were still wearing the leather pants
'cause I think they
couldn't afford other pants.
But it didn't matter anymore.
And kids are much more
easy about these things
and adults were kind of
ossified a little bit,
I suppose should say.
- Yeah, yeah.
Again, sure, that ties back
to the biology as well.
- I think, I think.
- (indistinct) The learning.
So lots that we could
learn from the younger ones
among us as well.
So as we wrap up,
I was also just going to ask a little bit
about some of the biology
that we've been touching on,
but of consolation behavior.
And then in this mode that we're in
of kind of the ups and
downs of the pandemic,
what that has also meant for us
as there haven't been as
the same types of ways
to express that consolatory behavior.
And if there are ways
that can also inform how
we interact moving forward,
because Larry, as you mentioned,
this is not something that's
going to be gone anytime soon.
So Larry, I guess we could start with you
as you've studied some of that as well.
- Yeah. I mean, I think,
so you mentioned consolation
that this is something that
we studied in the voles
where we see that if an
animal's partner is distressed
or someone they know is distressed,
they release the oxytocin
and it makes them be
tuned into that partner
and recognize that they're distressed
and then do something.
And I think that we're organized
in such a way that we can detect others
when they're in distress
and have some urge to help them.
And maybe we don't do that as much,
when we're isolated and things like that.
But I think just being aware
that this is something that we should do
that doing that, it's
the right thing to do.
Perhaps someone recognize
when someone is in distress,
it's also hard for us to know
when people are in distress.
We see them once in a while on Zoom,
we don't know what's going
on when they're alone.
And just to kind of be aware of,
ask people, how are you
doing and reach out to them
to help if they need help.
- Pat, anything you want
to add to that as well?
- Well, I was just
thinking of other species,
there was wonderful data that (indistinct)
has had chimpanzees
consoling other chimpanzees
and in the wild as well as in captivity.
But of course dogs are
incredible in that way too.
If you're upset or you're tearful
or you've fallen or,
the dog will come and they'll
nozzle and they'll lick,
and if it's a baby, I mean,
this used to be just
waved off as anecdotes.
But now there's so much real data
as well as lots and lots
of anecdotes on YouTube,
but it's hard to dismiss.
- I think one thing that has
happened during this pandemic
is that people have realized
how much of a lifeline
that their pets are.
- Yes, absolutely.
Because they really
have bonded emotionally
with their pets.
And their pets are a source of joy
and that's really social interaction
that's even as others.
And so that's something we sort of,
in the absence of other interactions,
we sort of built and strengthen that.
And that can help improve mental health.
But I do think that people
eventually need to wean
themselves off of only that.
(all laughing loudly)
Because having real
human social interactions
is so important for so many other things.
So yeah.
- One thing I've often wondered,
and I doubt there's any way
that anyone's looked at this,
it's just, some of the things
that you've talked about
in terms of the oxytocin being released
in certain interactions
and how that can also build trust,
whether that can also happen on Zoom,
if it happens to the lesser of.
- Yeah, that's a big deal.
- I know people have been
talking about that specifically.
- Yeah, yeah. That is a big deal.
- People have been talking about that
before Zoom, before the pandemic,
as people started texting.
So children who are with their mother
and hear the mother's voice
or their father engaging with them.
They have big peak of oxytocin,
but if you get a text, you don't.
And I'm sure that the oxytocin
release that you hear.
I mean, even if you're just
interacting with another person
and it's a positive interaction,
the eye to eye contact is
causing oxytocin release.
And that's like,
it's kind of like exercise
in your social brain.
You need that from a day to day basis.
And when you only get the
interactions through Zoom,
I don't think you're having
that same kind of interactions.
You don't feel the connections.
You're a 2D image that moves.
And yeah, so that's having
long-term impacts on them.
- There's was an additional thing here,
which is that oxytocin has
what is sometimes referred
to as a sibling peptide,
which is vasopressin.
And sometimes the release of vasopressin
can have to do with being
careful, anxiety, caution,
and so forth.
And it turns out that this
is work by Sue Carter,
that oxytocin can bind
to vasopressin receptors
with the upshot that there can be,
yeah, well, you know, yes, but maybe not.
And when I first read her paper,
I thought about some of the
male-female encounters one has,
especially for example, as a teenager.
Is he really being mean?
Or is that a joke?
Or I kind of liked him, but maybe not.
But I think those sorts
of complex dynamics,
those ambiguities are often in play
even when we are
contemplating helping someone
or wondering whether we
should give them shelter
and so forth.
Is it been (indistinct).
- You have to be vigilant on who you help.
- You have to be.
- And there's interesting work on rats
showing that an adult rat,
if they have a choice to
interact with a juvenile rat
that's in distress
versus another adult
male that's in distress,
they avoid that adult
male that's in distress.
And they help the female
because an adult who is in
distress could be (indistinct)
and that is also regulated by oxytocin-
- And vasopressin.
- These brain mechanisms.
So many of the things that
we engage in every day
that we don't even think about
what's going on in the brain.
We're starting to understand the hormones,
the chemicals in the
brain that's doing it,
but also now the circuitry,
we're learning more and
more about the circuitry
of how it's working
and how the consequences of
that are accumulating over years
to change our behavior.
And I think that the real,
what I'm really excited about the future
of this area of research,
is that there are a lot
of psychiatric disorders,
the depression where people
are withdrawn socially,
there's also autism or
schizophrenia and other areas,
psychiatric disorders,
where people are just resistant
to interacting socially
or uncapable.
That what we've been learning
through these animals
and with this oxytocin system
is how we might be able to
tweak the brain circuitry
and tweak these neurochemicals
so that we can help
improve the social outcome
of these disorders.
And that's really the reason
why I'm doing the work that I'm doing
is to try to to help us to
navigate the social world
in a better way.
- Yeah. Awesome.
- That's so exciting.
So encouraging in a lot of ways,
especially as you mentioned,
because it touches on so many different
mental health challenges
and psychiatric illnesses.
It really is key to how we
interact on a day-to-day basis.
- Oh yeah, and so complicated.
- I think in a lot of ways
the listeners will really enjoy
listening to this episode too.
And just maybe even self evaluating,
as there are so many anecdotes
just thinking about
our daily interactions.
'Cause I mean, even as we we're talking
about the difference
between Zoom and in person.
I mean, I'm thinking during certain times
during the pandemic,
just going to the grocery store
and making eye contact
with a complete stranger
and how elevating and
encouraging that felt
and could kind of lift me
through the rest of the day
as opposed to talking with
people I knew really well
just by Zoom.
So there's a lot there
and a lot that we're still
learning moving forward.
As a closing question,
what are the things that give you all hope
as we move forward in our world
with all that you know
about social bonding
and then also as we think about
how we continue to navigate the pandemic?
Pat, I guess we can start
with you in this one.
- Well, I think in lots of ways
people have really pulled together
and they've been very sensible
and tried to do the best they can.
I think there've been
many regrettable things
as we all know,
but there are these kinds of intervals
where humans fill us with despair,
and time moves on
and the despair changes to
optimism and hope and so forth.
And I mean, maybe this is
just an old lady speaking,
but I remain very hopeful about the future
and about how people will work together
to solve certain kinds of problems
even though maybe at the moment,
we wish that there was more cooperation
than lasts sort of theme calling.
- Yeah. I think in the
last couple of years,
our world has really been shaken up.
Mine was shaken up with the
politics and with COVID,
and just thinking about
what the future holds.
And so, yeah,
I think there was a depth in a deep spot
and that's why I sort of,
I changed my life,
I was trying to become healthy,
I lost like 40 pounds.
- I thought you did, yeah.
- Yeah, so I think we're
going to do the same thing
as a society they way we interact.
It's not just with COVID
it's politics, social injustice issues,
and all these things is really turmoil.
But we're going to get through this.
Pretty soon it's going
to be three years later,
four years later, five, 10 years later.
We're going to look back at that.
And we're going to say
that was a changing point.
And also in terms of the science,
we're going to think about
the things that we know.
And there have been a lot of changes
in terms of social justice
and attention to diversity
and things that have been happening.
I think that's going to continue
and I just like,
I'm an optimist,
so I like to see things that have happened
that were really bad in a positive light
because we're creating positive change.
- And I think they do actually.
And sometimes you just have to go
through this sort of
dark night at the soul
to come out at the other end
and really good things will happen.
(indistinct)
- We're more too in the baby boomers.
- Yeah, who knew?
- Yeah. Opportunity in a lot of ways.
- I think, I think.
- Well, definitely I appreciate
both of you being here.
Again, I think this is
going to be so enlightening
for a lot of folks
and encourage you to
listen to the insights
that you shared
and just a fascinating research
in all the different angles and nuances.
And I think just also,
just to have a better understanding
of how some of the animal models
and what we can learn
from the animal kingdom
about how we interact as humans as well,
and then just thinking developmentally.
So grateful to both of you
for taking time out of your schedules,
your busy schedules.
I'm impressed by both of your
exercise routines, by the way.
So that's something that is
going to have to encourage me
to put into action, hopefully.
- Yeah. Actually exercise
phrases the level of oxytocin.
There you go. It'll feel good.
Not that fast, but-
(Patricia laughs loudly)
- That's well said.
Thanks so much to both of you
for being on the "Addie Hour."
I definitely appreciate your time
and all the insights that you shared.
(bright upbeat music)